One thing the world needs, one thing this country desperately needs...
...is a better way of conducting our political debates.
We need to rediscover the lost art of democratic argument.
If you think about the arguments we have,...
...most of the time it's shouting matches on cable television,...
...ideological food fights on the floor of Congress.
I have a suggestion.
Look at all of the arguments we have these days over health care,...
...over bonuses and bailouts on Wall Street,...
...over the gap between rich and poor, over affirmative action and same-sex marriage.
Lying just beneath the surface of those arguments,...
...with passions raging on all sides,...
...are big questions of moral philosophy, big questions of justice.
But we too rarely articulate and defend and argue about those big moral questions in our politics.
So, what I would like to do today is have something of a discussion.
First, let me take a famous philosopher...
...who wrote about those questions of justice and morality,...
...give you a very short lecture on Aristotle of ancient Athens,...
...Aristotle's theory of justice,...
...and then have a discussion here...
...to see whether Aristotle's ideas actually inform the way we think and argue about questions today.
So, are you ready for the lecture?
According to Aristotle, justice means giving people what they deserve.
That's it. That's the lecture.
Now, you may say, "Well, that's obvious enough." The real questions begin...
...when it comes to arguing about who deserves what and why.